this war we're not winning it
speak a word of what I'm about to show
you you will be executed for high
treason it's beautiful it's the greatest
encryption device in history and the
Germans use it for all communications
everyone thinks enigma is unbreakable
let me try they won't know for sure mr.
Turing do you know how many time because
of it
I don't three while we've been having
this conversation gentlemen meet mr.
Turing we work together then I'm afraid
these men would only slow me down
popular at the school way short on staff
we get more staff then you have six
minutes to complete the task it's not
even possible no it takes me eight five
minutes and 34 seconds you said to do it
in under six what is it that we're
really doing we were going to break an
unbreakable Nazi code and win the war
[Music]
you know to pull off this irascible
genius routine one actually has to be a
genius I'm designing a machine that will
allow us to break every message every
day instantly
you're going to need all the help you
can get and they are not going to help
you if they do not like you have you
decrypted a single German message you
will never understand the importance of
what I am creating here our patience has
expired
No if you fire Helen well then you'll
have to fire me me too and me better
bloody well Helen you do not have to do
this alone
what you drink what's going on and
everything's that one of us is a Soviet
spy
you've got more secrets from the best of
them what if I don't fancy but in that
way don't tell anyone no it's a label
I'm just a mathematician sometimes
they're just people who no one imagines
anything on and do the things that know
[Music]